don't do the intro today now why not
[Laughter]
hey guys welcome to the heaven Halen
podcast the podcast for Kaylin gets
triggered so today we're gonna be doing
and I'll list things out properly we're
gonna be doing news that's really
exciting with a dirty secret at the end
we're gonna be telling the story of how
the supervisor entered our lives we will
not be playing a game and we all have a
thing that the week I mean Jen chose are
just reading the list in front of him it
did have game listed there so I'm gonna
delete that so it doesn't trip us up
later and sometimes we're not great with
our time estimates but I think the story
of the supervisor will it might go on
for a little bit because we'll probably
end up just telling random stories in
general about how the supervisor is
entertaining and a cute little sneaky
ninja of ninja so sneaky
words are easy alright so some news
updates we found a third editor for the
gaming channel yeah if you guys saw the
human fall flat dark level props to the
new editor yeah it's exciting to like
continue growing that team and
everything it's it's interesting how
building up a team for the gaming
channel has been you know it's been work
but it there haven't been that many
hiccups compared to like trying to I
think we've already talked about like
the main channel verse the the gaming
channel and stuff but it's really
exciting that we're making progress and
also once like the three editors can
maybe edit one per week that might be
enough to keep up with us in our
schedule yeah I mean hopefully we stream
more than once per week but some weeks
week once a week I don't know because if
all three added one that'll be three per
week oh yeah and then and then we should
be good which is really exciting
it's like figuring things out moving the
business along like it's really cool
that would be great we can stream so
much more Mike
it's so hard not to like
the other day we try to go in and just
play a casual stream where we're just
like doing maintenance around our little
world or maybe like a maintenance and
chat stream where it's like we just do
stuff and if you're not familiar with
Minecraft we're just doing stuff like
making food for us to take on journeys
like building the second story to our
house plants from our farm yeah like the
kind of stuff that typically isn't the
most interesting for like a gaming
highlight that goes on the channel but
then like everything kept watch being
like okay can I do the crate harvesting
of the cows we have like calafate can I
turn a sheep into a rainbow sheep can I
make a rainbow can I go explore that
cave and just get some more iron now I'm
like no cave exploits for the highlight
yeah but then you gave in with me then
you start building the seconds to worry
yeah cuz we found the pink sheep we had
to we found a natural pink sheep we
found a natural pink sheep and like that
triggered the whole thing oh we got
triggered yeah it's just it's just
really fun the gaming channel continues
to be like a awesome break from our like
daily routines that like pulls us out of
like yeah continual hustle mode even
though it's like a side hustle
it's a side hustle mode it's different
it's interesting to me and like this
just took me a little bit to get on
board with before we started hiring out
others because the gaming channel we
like just recently monetized it so it
gets some YouTube ad money but it's very
little and we don't we haven't got any
sponsors there cuz you know the views
just aren't really enough to justify the
amount of time and work it would take to
do a sponsor yeah um but so we're
spending more money on the gaming
channel then we're spending on the main
channel yeah that's crazy
you know the main channel is what like
gives us income oh you know what the
recent camera purchases and upgrades we
did spend a decent amount yeah we did on
but that we can use for all over the
channels not really because gaming
channel is just this camcorder which we
already had yeah but at the same time I
mean you know we've talked about it
enough and we must forget how much we've
talked about things on the podcast but
there's no other way to start up this
channel 100% it would have just like and
not fizzled I still think we would be
streaming but I don't think the gaming
channel would really be much I think
we'd just be streaming really and we can
like upload our old streams on YouTube
in their entirety but like I don't want
that to be what the channel is not that
there's anything wrong with that a lot
of sumers do that this stream and then
they highlight the whole stream to
youtube I think we just want to if we're
if we're putting something if we're
reapplying content not really but if
we're putting something on YouTube we
want it to be different than what's
already on Twitch yeah even though oh my
gosh the twits Twitch's library it's not
horrible it's so confusing it's bad yeah
we have had some people ask if we're
gonna put the full streams on YouTube
but I don't think we will just cuz like
imagine if you're someone who's watching
and you're just watching for the
highlights and that's the main thing
you're watching for but then every other
video is you know an hour to two hour
long stream you might unsubscribe
because you're like oh I don't want to
be getting notifications for yeah the
only thought that I've had is uploading
videos unlisted it to an unlisted
playlist or like just like about public
playlists but the videos won't be sent
out as notifications and then you can
watch like our past streams in a
playlist form but still yeah we'll see
well we're still figuring it out yeah as
this a little bit obvious but you know
who just figured out something really
cute our supervisor okay so so a lot of
people asked like does she still use the
catio she using the catio did she like
the catio and the answer has been yes
but she hadn't been using it a ton like
it slowed down and last month or so
because houston it's so hot it's so hot
and so we're like well you know I guess
that me
make sense but then she recently
discovered catio in night mode and she
loves it as soon as it gets dark she's
like at the door and she'll either let
herself in or she'll just stay there and
like look at us yeah and she just goes
out there and just like disappears
disappears into the blackness yeah
because there's no light she is just a
little ninja and it's just so cute
knowing she's out there just doing her
own thing we can't see her she's just
out there so cute it kind of makes me
one like expand the patio to multiple
windows maybe even like make a little
catwalk catwalk a catwalk between our
two windows she can go from our bedroom
to the living room like outside like a
little tunnel door the living room in
our bedroom we're both against the back
of the house and so sometimes she'll be
in the living room or there's like a
squirrel or something outside that she's
really into in the squirrel runs past
where she could see from the living room
in Windows so she like runs backwards
goes down the hall around the hall to
the hole you turn around the house to
get to our bedroom so yeah that would be
cool she had like a little catwalk in
between maybe future project yeah maybe
well speaking of updates on past
projects we have a dirty secret that
we're gonna share with you during the
garage cleanup it's just like something
that we see every single day and we just
want to like fess up to it but um during
the garage cleanup we like quarantined a
whole bunch of items that we're like we
still need to deal with this or we need
to reorganize these or we need to
repaint them or you know it's like these
are our problem children of the garage
everything out there is good and
organized and great and it stayed
organized which is good but we do have
this pile of stuff that's just still
kind of sitting there yeah it's like a
large pile it's not a ton of individual
items it's just like some of the large
items
yeah but it's all stuff that like mmm I
think all of it is keep stuff but it all
has to do is hide to it you know we
didn't just want to like
shove it in a cabinet and forget about
those to do so an example is like clamp
storage we never had good clamp storage
we had our clamps in like five different
places before in the garage and so all
of our clamps are inside and that's a
lot of stuff and so we finally figured
out some clamp storage and we you know
just bought some stuff cuz we'd have
time to make anything and now that's
just sitting in a pile too but like it's
things like that where we didn't want to
just throw all of our clamps like into a
cabinet and close the door because we
wanted to make a storage right yeah we
could have we have the space now but
like I want to put things back properly
like by Caitlin saying and that you know
it's just it to do that we haven't
gotten to because like your mom came
over the other day yeah and she hadn't
been to the house since we like did the
garage makeover and she's like click
over there she's like yeah we also had
someone come in we had some wasps in our
house or was it wasps yellowjacket
Yellowjackets and he's like are you guys
like resellers or something like I've
you like sell stuff on Amazon he'll so
confused he told all this stuff just
like sitting around on tables and stuff
and he was so confused yeah well we're
scheduling it I was like oh we both work
from home so anytime works yeah it was
pretty funny yeah I was like no we make
things
yeah it's like it's a whole spiel well
I'll explain it anyways well that I
think brings us around to the story of
the supervisor okay this is my favorite
part of the story
I'm gonna I'm gonna kind of like jump
around a little bit but Caitlin has
always loved cats from like when you
were like a little very little kid I've
had cats like since I was born and
you've always just adored them even when
they might not love you back oh yeah I
went through some some hard life lessons
with with cats they didn't love me the
way that I loved them
that was like four I remember my
grandma's cat
her name was foxy she was a foxy lady
she she also apparently she farted all
the time but like I would just come up
and like she's let me give her one pet
I'd be like oh she likes me I tried
another very traumatizing very normal
for a cat but like you know when you're
four yeah very sad always always look at
so so I think Caitlyn has always had the
plan that she wants to get her own cat
as soon as possible but Caitlyn is also
very responsible she is responsible and
she likes to have a plan yes what was
the plan the plan was to get a cat
so okay let me back up a little bit yeah
at our College it was and this isn't
common for most but it was common for
people to live on on-campus housing all
four years which is kind of a rare thing
but so I was on campus all four years
can't have cats on campus so as soon as
I graduated and I was getting my own
apartment I was like I'm gonna get a cat
but I'm gonna be responsible and I'm
gonna at least get a bed no I was gonna
get all my furniture I was like I'm
gonna furnish the apartment and then
I'll get a cat it was like a good
motivator
to like get the apartment set up like I
wanted to move in I still had just boxes
of dorm stuff um and so I got a bed I
got a couch and then I got a bed couch
done literally I had that and then just
like some Rubbermaid containers of like
dorm junk when and you got like a white
couch right yeah well okay so so I was
looking because I was like so excited to
get a cat I was looking at like the
shelter's online and seeing a lot a lot
of the shelters have like photos of the
cats that they have and I noticed like a
lot of them were light-colored cats and
they didn't have all of the cats it was
just like a decent amount of photo so a
lot of them were like light-colored
tabbies on this and that and I was like
you know what I'm shopping for a couch
today
I'm gonna get like a capsules kind of on
the light side like a topi kind of color
so I went shopping I bought the couch
and then uh no and I was in my mom and I
was like oh there's a we were kind of
like slightly on the other side you have
a couch in the car no no I'd ordered it
oh you'd ordered it okay I literally
just bought it and we were on the other
side of town and one of the shelters
that I looked at that was kind of
farther from my apartment that I might
know how to drive out who was right near
the French right now you know ha ha ha
next thing I know I'm like in my happy
place sitting on the floor of the animal
shelter with like all of the kitten the
best thing ever by the way it's like
being in the kitten cage it's amazing
it's my dream no slaying with kittens I
was playing with like older cats I was
like playing with a bunch of them and
there was this one who you know and you
can only get out like usually it's just
like one at it at a time really unless
they're super friendly and get along
with all of them and there's this one so
that they're like crates were stacked
vertically and one that was about at
like I don't know mid level hypeeeeee
there was this tiny little fluffy black
paw that kept popping out and like like
bopping my arm uh-huh
like when I would be standing up and I
was like I was like I see you little
black kitten but I just bought a white
couch ha ha ha and so I was like playing
with the other cats and then like she
just kept like getting my attention and
I was like oh my gosh she's so freaking
cute she's so freaking cute okay I'll
just well I'll just play with the black
and I just want to like play with her
and you a lot of times kittens are kind
of skittish they all like you know they
might like come over and give you love
but then they also might like freak out
and go over there or they might be
really scared or they might try to hide
like they're not as calm as older cats
so sometimes they're kind of all over
the place and it's hard to like get a
feel for their personality in shelters
if they're not in a calm mood and so all
the kittens I had played with were kind
of you know they had their zoomies and
they're getting their zoomies on and
running around all over the place
then I like grab this little black kit
and I you know put her on the floor in
front of me and she just immediately
crawls in my lap and just lays there and
I'm like Chozen and it was just like oh
my eyes I'm cute and I was like she's
the one the one he's the one so I
brought her home I didn't even have the
couch in your bed and like an empty
floor yeah and then I had a fluffy super
fluffy black kitten and then my white
couch so great so did they tell you
where where she came from where they
found her she was found at a mall in the
mall parking lot
hmm somebody found her and brought her
in so mall cat yeah she's a little mall
cat um she was really tiny she was so
tiny that like they when I first adopted
her they couldn't like fix her yet small
for the for the surgery I tried to keep
her for like several weeks before they
could even do a little surgery on her so
so small she had have been there
I know I know yeah you weren't Houston
at the time yeah we weren't dating yet
we're only friends still yeah but yeah
oh so freaking cute I was gonna say like
speaking of the catio this isn't the
first thing that you've built for her
no no I'm well I mean in my apartment so
um there was like a little like a pretty
decently sized room for pudding if you
want to tell you rent laundry machines
um like imagine the footprint that a
washer dryer takes up times two you know
yeah and so without the washer and dryer
in there it was like it was like a
really really big empty closet basically
it was like an awkward place yeah you
could really only use it as like a
closet and I was too cheap to rent a
washer/dryer cuz I walk down and use the
ones of the apartment like you know
lobby not lobby you know the common area
Tommy
yeah you know and so I turned it into
kiddie Kingdom and it was basically like
you know those um kind of like
reconfigurable wire some reconfigured
configurable wire storage units but I
set it up to where it was like a
stair-step almost mmm so it was imagine
like square cubbies but they stair step
down so and then I like put little
towels and bedding and every cubby and
like had a bunch of toys in there and so
she could kind of climb to the top of it
or go into any cubby and I had a bunch
of toys and that's where I had like our
food and water and stuff mm-hmm
and just like all sorts of fun kitten
stuff like a little like like cat closet
it's like DZ play zone but what else was
I gonna do I of course I had to build a
cap changer I was like recent recent
college grad using my time wisely that's
awesome misuse it at all yeah yeah how
do we need to build a kitty Kingdom 2.0
maybe I mean she probably like yeah they
make expand the catio we don't have room
in the house weak stand outside yeah
well I think um when I met her how old
was she um she was almost a year almost
here so she loved you and she didn't
really like anyone else no and she's
still kind of like aside from you you
have passed the test now I've passed the
test yeah it took about a year for her
to like really like trust me and like
curl up on me and love me and stuff but
yeah she she she has four people mm-hmm
that's pretty much it didn't you think
about it like she took to you and you
were kind of you were one of the first
other people that she spent any
significant amount of time yeah around
and if you think about other people like
she's a lot more hesitant about them
than she was meeting you
hmm you know right she she wasn't
necessarily like cuddling with you
immediately but she wouldn't hide yeah
she didn't like his that you or anything
well I think that you might have I'm not
sure how much crap you gave me but I
knew like I was pretty good with like
cat etiquette
yeah which is definitely anything yeah
yeah definitely thing yeah yeah I did
kind of like prep you a little bit me
trying to prep other people to campus
like go up to cat yeah like treat them
like a dog yeah cats are dogs yeah yeah
some cats or dogs
some cats yeah but most cats aren't like
dogs at all yeah but I mean we moved in
together like well we didn't we didn't
move in together for 10 months that you
were here you were in my apartment every
weekend so she got pretty used to seeing
you and then we started doing we called
it kidnappings like where I I was
freelancing at the time and so we would
we would schedule a kidnapping we're
basically like Evan would come to my
apartment we'd you know spend the
weekend there and then Monday or Sunday
night you just take me and Moki back
with you yeah and we would stay your
apartment for like two weeks and I would
just work from there so much fun
oh my gosh so then she got used to your
apartment oh yeah yeah so she got you so
our apartment like gradually yeah but
she was like she adapted to it pretty
quickly yeah you know and she she's
she's a cat that like does fine on car
rides you know as long as she's not
going to the vet well as long as you're
with her you're like like touch her and
reassure her and stuff like that so yeah
but um so like she didn't mind the rides
and she likes being at your apartment
which is like so surprising actually
that was hard sometimes well cats are
very like they're creatures of habit and
they don't like change you know and so
I'm kind of surprised that she like took
to it so immediately but I was there she
took this the change to this house
pretty well too yeah she did she's lived
in three different places
yeah she's moved pretty well yeah but
yeah so um
she did kind of have like some time to
get you see you in like first and
weekend chunks and then in like two week
long chunks at a time and then I moved
in mm-hmm and then she already like knew
you pretty well as well as we had a
common bond we both loved Kaitlyn very
much and we respected each other's
boundaries it's a relationship built
upon trust I feel like I feel like she's
pretty well bonded to you now oh yeah
yeah yeah you know she I'm still the one
that like feeds her and like cleans up
most of her poop yeah
I still like serve her I think I still
have a little bit of a priority yes she
hops up on your lap first well often
she'll curl up on my lap - yeah yeah I
think also she knows because like I'm I
have I would say like slower movements
you know whereas sometimes you'll just
be like well I've never been aware of
where my limbs are and sound like I
think sometimes she has to be like kind
of more on guard if she's like next to
you because you might just like reach
over and she's like well you know yeah
y-you do dad also you you you play with
her a little bit more than I do you like
like she to words there's too many more
names for our cat monkey supervisor wan
jube
that's the dusty mode that she do drew
Kim yeah bear yep lots lots of names but
um so Julie loves boxes like all cats do
but you'll be also loves being pulled
around in the box oh yeah so you you
will more often like pull her around in
the boxes do the zoomies with her and
stuff like that because she's like she's
one of my if I'm like editing for too
long I need a break she's like my
perfect break excuse you know what I
mean so it's like I'm like well I could
pull out my phone and browse reddit for
a few minutes or I could like go find
Juby and like play with her slash annoy
her for a few minutes
like a hide-and-seek moment too because
because he doesn't have like contrast in
her coloring like lots of cats hair like
you know white and brown or like
different shades or anything like that
no mokey is just like pure black
sometimes we'll play find the cat like
if I know where she is
and like stand in the spot do you see
well it's also it's like there are other
black lumps like if you put through your
black jacket on the couch I often think
that's Juby or like like that or a black
backpack I'm like oh oh that's not our
cat that's the backpack so so and she
also hides in corners and in our closets
and stuff like that so sometimes fun to
like go around and try to find her yeah
it is fine oh yeah so she's like one of
my little breaks so we get more like
playing time together I think yeah yeah
but you could you could win her over
you could win her friend me by bribery
yes I'm treats yeah oh yeah I know the
way
yeah but she still she loves you all I
do and sometimes I think it's also like
habit like she's gonna sleep on the same
side of the bed no matter what oh yeah
it happens to be my side anymore like
her favorite is right in between us your
favorite like in the little pocket
between us yeah that's her like well
speaking of habits and happy places when
it was time for us to make a new website
for evident Caitlyn gaming guess where
we went
Squarespace squarespace.com because we
they had really easy templates it was
really easy to make a format by the way
if you don't know this is that spot
those really easy to make a new website
drop all of our like embeds in drop the
videos in and bad the twitch playlists
and stuff like that and it was really
just a happy place to go back to yep
it's a great habit before I'm trying to
like my feet into your Segway I was
trying I was trying it was good yeah and
if you don't want to be in the habit of
dealing with annoying plugins or your
website crashing you know Squarespace is
definitely a good place to go to yeah
and when you're ready to start taking
your business or side hustle or whatever
you need a website for seriously you can
go to Squarespace comm to get a free
trial and when you're ready to start
like many of our listeners and viewers
have squarespace.com slash evident
podcast to get 10% off your first
purchase sorry I didn't know you're
gonna put me on the spot yeah
squarespace.com slash Evan Catelynn
podcast to get 10% off right back to the
podcast I thought it'd be fun to tell
one of the stories of one of our very
first projects that we did for the
apartment together which was for the
supervisor oh yeah yeah the IKEA catbox
and we had a documented on our old blog
oh my god it got picked up by a lot of
different blogs and stuff too like it
did like pretty good on Pinterest and
other blogs
oh yeah and that was like I think that
we might have told the story before but
before we started to do in YouTube we
tested read it out to see like like how
rad it works and what communities to
post on and everything and we posted the
IKEA hack cat box and it like went made
it to the front page and we're like we
understand the internet and then nothing
else has ever done that well but so what
we did is we took IKEA has this line
called like beste and it's very modular
set of different sized cabinets that you
can arrange in different ways and it's
typically for like media centers like
media consoles and stuff but they have
these smaller single like two unit beste
cabinets so it's just like a two unit
wide low cabinet that's about a foot and
a half deep so anyways we we had done
like a beste media center kind of thing
and so we were kind of familiar with the
cabinets and you know in my apartment I
had key Kingdom which is where I could
put like her litter box and stuff but
you didn't you're um like laundry room
and your apartment was just like a
vertical stack there wasn't like a room
yeah you're right and so we were like
well where are we gonna put her stuff
was she in that was she in the bathroom
for a while no I think we just
immediately went to this
oh wow the bathroom didn't really have
like a good nook or anything it was like
been right in the middle what who's been
right in the middle of the floor like
there was no like nook to tuck it back
into yeah and so there was like no good
place for her box and we were like okay
well we don't just want to have it in
the middle it's like do we put it in our
bedroom in the bathroom in the living
room or in the kitchen well and one
other interesting challenge there not
really a challenge but like the other
objective that we had for this is we
also wanted it to hide the litter box
but we also wanted it to reduce the
amount of litter tracked out oh yeah cuz
she is she is one that like scrambles
she scrambles she runs out of her litter
box like the poop is chasing her yeah
just like runs away from it as fast as
she can and so she leaves like a trail
of kitty litter behind her and so we're
we wanted to help contain that
especially if she didn't have her own
room to like have it in and so what we
did we took this to unit beste we had
one unit with a full cabinet door on the
left side so so picture this two unit
thing full cabinet door on the left on
the right the top portion was a skiddy
pullout drawer with a cabinet under it
and again this is all like
reconfigurable you can do what you want
there's a divider down the middle that
we cut a cat sized opening out of mm so
that the two were connected in the left
full cabinet side we put a litter box in
the right that was slightly shorter we
put a litter mat and then in the drawer
we stored things like extra cat toys cat
food stuff like that
like her or no we didn't put the food in
there we had extra toys and like her
litter scooper and like plastic bags
yeah and so we had this totally little
self-contained unit and then we
installed a cat door on the side on the
far right exterior side and so she would
go in and out of the cat door she'd walk
over the litter mat go through the
opening into the litter box and then
she'd go out the other way and she kind
of couldn't run out of it because sized
openings you know and the loader mat
helped
everything and now it works super well
it worked three years years years years
years and then like a year into owning
the house she decided she didn't like it
anymore well I think the main thing is I
think the main reason always to kind of
stopped using it is when we upgraded the
laundry room and we like hid her new box
in its new location under the cabinets
kind of tucked in and everything there
but she had kind of grown less fond of
it gradually after moving into the house
like I think in the apartment it was
fine she was totally used to it and for
whatever reason also maybe because it
was like fresh and new and maybe like we
just can't couldn't clean it as well
yeah I mean we tried to clean it but
it's also like particle board so it
probably did have like a an end to its
life in sight it wasn't gonna last
forever it'd be different if it was like
a different material I bet now we could
make an even better one I think we don't
need it we don't need it but we could
like kind of like I think that there
have been some suggestions online of
like adding some lights above her her
areas that she can like see a little bit
maybe like like having some windows in
there so that she's like private yes she
can also monitor yeah of light yeah yeah
yeah but I think I think we could have
done things I think we didn't think
about it in the beginning because she
just like took to it immediately yeah
you know so we're like oh work is great
but then when she started not using it
once we moved we like weren't too sure
we did try like keeping the cabinet door
open but then I kind of like defeats the
purpose of having it all concealed in
this little thing and so we ended up
going with the just tucking it into a
cubby and the new laundry room makeover
and she likes that yeah um but also
sometimes cats just like change we
haven't had that many failed cat
projects though like that she didn't
take - yeah she loves her scratching
post yeah she loves the catio yeah we've
done two different scratching post one
that just lays on the floor and one
that's vertical if she likes the
vertical one more but when we only had
the file and she still used it she use a
lot yeah yeah she just stubbed our toes
a lot yeah
yeah I prefer the vertical and we might
do a new vertical one sometime like an
updated version it was one of our first
projects on the channel yeah well like
the one that we made it was just for the
side of a couch but she likes the corner
of the couch yeah so I think we need to
make another one that wraps around the
corner of the couch yeah for some reason
she likes corners yeah it's like a
scratching post slash couch armor yeah
I'm trying of when we started calling
her the supervisor I think it was the
first summer that we were doing the
channel before we had a/c in the garage
there was a few projects but it was just
so hot we're like okay we're just gonna
do as much of this project as we can
inside and I think one of the first ones
was our entryway shelf a little light
coat hanger oh yeah I remember we did
like the cuts outside but we did all the
gluing and assembly and all that we just
laid out a big tarp in our living room
and did it in there because it was so
freakin hot and so she would hang out on
the couch and just watch us the whole
time and so and there was a few times or
she was in the shot like in the
foreground of the shot and she was on
the couch like they liked my words the
lot L of the couch and so she was like
her head was barely in frame and you
could just see her watching us and I
remember popping text on the screen and
calling her like the supervisor cuz she
was like because she was watching the
whole time we were working I almost
forgot the origin I thought we just
decided that she was the supervisor from
the beginning it's always been the super
I think it was cuz like when she when we
started doing some projects inside that
summer because it was too hot she would
always be nearby like watching us like
she was supervising our work you know
and so I popped it in and text I don't
know if I spelled it with the like pu RR
at the time that might have come later
but I think that's when it started was
that video that's the first time I have
a memory of doing that and yet it that's
crazy
yeah origin of the supervisor yeah and
now she just she's still like if we're
inside doing a project she's on cuz
usually if we're inside were in the
living room and she's on the couch just
watching us
and when we're in the garage she often
this isn't the case if we're using power
tools of really using loud stuff she
doesn't have any desire to be in there
and we wouldn't want her in there anyway
but if we're not doing anything with
power tools and she can just hear us
talking
she'll often be right at the garage door
oh yeah that's so cute and she'll she'll
sit on if you've seen other on our
laundry room makeover we have our like
top open chest freezer with the wooden
top that we built and it's right next to
the garage door so she'll sit on that so
she's at like counter height and she'll
just sit there and then we open the door
and she's just like right there right
next to her faces like oh hey she's
right there she's she's supervising
auditorially yeah and then sometimes if
we were in there too long she'll start
me out sometimes Caitlin should take a
break and she's like okay and sometimes
sometimes we will let her out in there
it's cleaner now cleaner now but it's
still not like great yeah often times
we're doing things like with sanding or
dust or if it's too dusty or if like if
we're in the middle of a resin pour and
we like the you know we are gonna have
sticky hands and we can't like you know
I don't know I don't know what she would
do you know cuz she usually just like
finds a cool hiding spot
ya know our Justin watches but like what
if she wants to hop up and we need to
like deal with her and we have messy
hands we just like we just don't want
that to be a concern yeah we want to be
safe or we don't want her like
accidentally being underfoot if we're
like in rush mode cuz yeah you know the
resin is kicking so so we don't let her
on the garage a ton when we're working
but every now and then well I think it's
time for a thing of the week
so my thing of the week is actually
right here it is the Raspberry Pi 4 we
have it for an upcoming project it won't
be like that cool of a Raspberry Pi
project we're basically using it just
it's a cool project it's a cool project
we're not doing anything too fancy with
raspberry pie no custom programming no
nothing customers it's kind of an
interesting little device for such a
small price and it's pretty capable and
everything so I'm excited to show you
guys and like do you wanna say what so
far I've put it in a case I've used it
I've installed steam links and now we
can like use our main computers to play
big games but the Raspberry Pi this kind
of feeds the signal to another TV and
for like the price that it is it's a
really good deal for something that you
can stream games with and also you can
use it for like web surfing or whatever
else how much is a steam link steam link
was 40 when it was launched or like 50
so the Raspberry Pi is 35 or something
like that so so it's cheaper and it can
do more stuff it's cheaper Anna can do
more stuff so it's kind of a neat little
package yeah it's like you you kind of
have to have a little bit more know-how
just plug and play like Steam link so
you know so pretty cool though so pretty
cool yeah kind of like go down the path
oh i all said one thing fancy I use the
GPIO pins on it to install a little fan
like using like yeah there's a little
fan no it's right there yeah identified
that as a fan basic stuff but it's like
interesting to go down that path a
little bit mm-hmm what's your thing of
the week my thing the week is so we got
these silicon measuring cups oh yeah and
we got them in a few different sizes and
we got them before doing the soap
because for like the resin projects
we've been using like paper cup cups we
yeah we have the UM a mixture so we have
we got one of those like packs of little
paper cups that you use for like you put
them in a guest bathroom to like brush
your teeth with you know
um I think like mouthwash and stuff
mouthwash yeah yeah not brush your teeth
with the cops but like if you like want
to rinse your mouth out with water or
something oh yeah yeah yeah so we got a
pack of those little paper cups and then
we had had total boat when they sent us
the resin they included a bunch of
buckets so we have like a big supply of
bucket so we've been using that and the
bucket sometimes we can reuse but
they're also so big that for little
individual colors we would use the
little cups but we're like oh man we're
going through a lot of cups yeah and so
we've been looking for something we can
reuse and Evan found these little well
we have two sides refuge's okay we have
these little measuring cups that are
just a little bit bigger than the paper
ones that we were using and they're like
a great size and they have a little pour
spout yeah which is awesome and there
they are a little hard to clean because
like something when the resin is like
too thin of a sheet it kind of flakes
and yeah I do get it kinda like get it
out with water and like subscription and
stuff like yeah yeah yeah and you can
pop them inside out which is nice to
like really clean off and it worked
great for like the soap too so yes I'm
for soap and resin so far and then we
have these bigger ones that you know
then the little ones you could get a set
of like three or nine or something and
they're not too expensive we did get
some bigger ones that are like oxo brand
more expensive that are more expensive
they're like ten dollars apiece but
they're so nice they're so nice they're
like real sturdy they're much easier to
clean plain little plastic ones yeah and
they have like very clear measuring
marks too on the big ones which is good
because the little ones we don't really
use them for measuring we just use them
for like individual color mixing but the
bigger ones we use it for like we need
to go up to a certain amount because
that's where we like we'll pump our
resin into to mix it and we use it to
actually measure - yeah so it's nice to
like cut down on waste and just buy
something once and we can use it going
forward for a long time I don't really
see the silicone wearing out unless we
like heat it up too much and it gets to
people it's like pretty sturdy silicone
and we use it on the the soap - we're
probably use in the future if we do like
other melt melting things that we have
in mind I'm sure you guys can guess like
maybe one but we have to I wonder which
one that guess that could be melted and
turned into other things yeah I think
they'd be good for like kitchen stuff
too like the oxo ones are I think made
for kitchen use kitchen use yes yeah so
if you're if you wanna be normal you can
also use them for normal things about we
use them for non normal thing yeah yeah
alright guys well I really appreciate
you guys spending your time with us on
today's podcast and if you haven't given
us a five star review yet we really
appreciate that it helps the algorithm
know that we're an awesome podcast and
it uses your recommendation to show it
to more people which will grow the
audience and keep us like going fYI that
we're recording this really early in the
morning for us and my brain isn't on yet
fully so that's my excuse and I'm
sticking to it yeah but today's last day
cuz we record this on Fridays you guys
are listening on Mondays but okay guys
[Music]